all good things they say must come to an
end
and so too must the scheme that many in
the hospitality industry say has given
them a lifeline
borough markets arabica bar and kitchen
along with 84
000 others signed up to the eat out to
help out scheme which for three days a
week offered discounts
of up to 10 pounds per person on their
meals
they were more like two weekends in a
week so that's the level you have during
during christmas time because the whole
week's busy with christmas parties
but that's how it's been so we've been
busy our weekends and also monday to
wednesday
uh wednesday just gone was our the most
reservations we ever had
in one day uh since we opened seven
years ago
financed by the government it was
designed to encourage customers back
into cafes and restaurants
64 million meals served up under the
scheme
show that it worked but it ends today
despite calls from the industry
for it to be extended you've seen high
streets begin to reinvigorate
you've seen people pop into shops as
well as go out and get some food
and you've got this sense now that
people have gone out and they've done
something good
they've supported their local small
business community and one way to
guarantee
this continues is to have it all
throughout september as well
those who are taking advantage of the
scheme agree
yeah i think restaurants should
definitely keep doing it i've certainly
been out
much more sort of monday to wednesday
since they've had the scheme
uh and i love it if restaurants kept it
going i'm a nurse
so having worked throughout the pandemic
is a really nice way to
start to socialize again and in a lot
more accessible way
chancellor rishi sunak launched the
scheme back in july
but with a government debt of around two
trillion pounds to tackle
he seems reluctant to extend it instead
urging people to keep dining out
to maintain the momentum so many
restaurants have decided to keep the
offer going
and to fund it themselves the incentive
from
richie has definitely had an impact and
a positive one
to give some formal normality to the
lives of
the public so we thought you know what
is time for us to do something as well
and we decided to carry on that scheme
for
september at one time over 80 percent of
staff
working in the hospitality sector were
on furlough
now that figure is less than 30 but this
is still an industry in dire straits
and the removal of this
government-backed promotion can only
make things harder
fraser moored sky news